[Music]
my name is moby dick the b stands for
bodacious i'm max pleasure ziggy
moonlight johnny gentlemen king molasses
also known as the sweetest and stickiest
drag king you'll ever meet
when i first saw drag kings perform i
remember being like
why hasn't nobody told me
about this
i was completely mesmerized wondering
why have i not done this before i got
hooked right away just being on that
stage and having the light hit me and i
feel like i'm finally me i feel the
fullness of myself when i'm in drag as
drag kings we're stepping out of the box
of who we were told we were allowed to
be and people think it's only new now
but it's not new i think the history of
drag kings has been very much obscured
it hasn't always been the way that we
understand it today but it's always been
drag is just the performance of gender
the performance the absence the
transformation of gender the majority of
drag kings are afir performers assigned
female at birth i do however know that
there are gamer performers who also
perform drag kings and also lots of
trans performers it's about playing with
masculine identities masculine
performativity whether that's
politicizing it vulgarizing it making it
a farce making it silly
you know you could create this character
you could say whatever you want you
could do whatever you want and people
laugh whether it's clowning striptease
dancing singing i might do a monologue
to music i draw a lot of inspiration
from american rock stars i definitely am
going for the bad boy with a heart of
gold type of thing
can i say i'm a hoe on camera is that
cool
i'm kind of a hoe when i perform that
swag you get in the shower that like
nobody sees it feels like that i'm a
latin poppy
which is like a latin sex symbol kind of
guy it surprised me when i even started
incorporating like a lot of cultural
elements into my drag even the palm hat
that i'm wearing now a lot of men from
where my mom's village in nigeria in
warri a lot of them wear
big
wide
very present hats and they they walk
with big broad shoulders and
drag takes me there especially being a
trans masculine non-binary latin next
person i just want to make sure that
every time i hit the stage that
there's somebody in the crowd hopefully
that when they see me they see
themselves
performing femininity was something that
i constantly felt like i was failing at
it's funny that
transforming and becoming an alter ego
is what allowed me to finally accept and
love myself for who i was and i started
using they them pronouns as molasses
before i started using they them
pronouns for myself
so it
just has been this really rewarding
experience where
it's a way to navigate the world and
make sense of things
a lot of people don't know there's this
long history of drag kings
a chinese scholar has male impersonation
dating back to the tongue dynasty and so
male impersonation in the chinese opera
started then then it moved to the west
there were pioneers like annie hindell
vesta tilly ella westner to our
knowledge the first indigenous male
impersonator is guango mohawk and she
was in the early 1900s and she
specifically wrote a play because she
did not like the way indigenous people
were depicted in theater during that
time there were many females and
lesbians that
were doing male impersonation as a way
of expressing themselves and to
protest against what defines being a
woman then moving on in the 1920s gladys
bentley came out as the forerunner in in
harlem dressing in men's attire was a
prolific performer
cross-dressing became illegal and it was
a crime people that came out and did
that were real true blue pioneers like
soul may delivery
someone who
epitomized what it meant to be black
what it meant to be masculine
what it meant to be strong what it meant
to be swaggy male impersonators were
more refined
it wasn't drag in the reset sense of the
comedic camp element the first time we
see drag king in print was in 1972
it's the queen's vernacular a gay
lexicon and in that it defines drag king
so that was the first time that we have
found that in prince there was this huge
thriving scene in the 90s in new york
city in san francisco and london
and you know other parts of the world
drag kings are
growing and they're getting bigger and
bigger but
they still got a way to go when it comes
to representation within cabaret and the
drag industry as a whole
you know rupaul's drag race is so
fantastic because so many drag queens
have become celebrities and pop culture
figures thanks to rupaul's drag race
that has not happened for drag kings yet
you know we don't wear heels but
we
give story we give the drama we give
emotion energy just like queens do
because we're not in the mainstream we
don't have the same opportunities as an
afab person i've had producers tell me
before that i was unsellable and that's
why they didn't book me what i do
want is for folks to acknowledge the
power of misogyny we are usurping male
power and privilege and that's still
scary to people our patriarchal society
doesn't really take kindly to the idea
that masculinity and manhood is
something that anyone can put on
it's tiresome but the great news is drag
kings have been in other reality
television competition shows and one
we've got hugo girl in 2018 who won in
new zealand landon cider in 2019 who won
dracula tenderoni in chicago who won in
2021. i'm hopeful i'm i'm optimistic
and in the meantime we're not waiting so
this new generation of kings that are
coming up on the scene the last 5-10
years
is shaking up the scenes in
a lot of different ways we're making our
own platforms we're taking up space in
platforms that have traditionally been
dominated by by cis men all of us are
starting a revolution to
be seen to fight for respect because
that's what we deserve i firmly believe
that us drag kings will make our mark
like we're kind of the coolest we've
kind of always been the coolest because
we're kind of counter-culture within a
counter-culture within a counter-culture
how punk is that
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
you